what's the difference between this shot
and this shot they're from the same
franchise just a few years apart what
exactly is the camera doing that makes
these similar shots feel so different
from each other okay
one more what about this shot and this
shot did you catch it
Casino Royale makes two subtle changes
to the cinematography that resultant
looking completely different from all of
the Bond films that precede it to find
out what exactly it's doing and why it's
doing it we have to go back to the
beginning of the franchise for the
overwhelming majority of Bond films
before Casino Royale the cinematography
appears to have been an afterthought the
lighting was flat the composition was
boring and the cinematography didn't do
anything to advance character or story
while action scenes adequately showcased
the set pieces and quality set and
production design helped mask the
cinematic shortcomings in general there
was very little artistry put into the
cinematography James Bond is supposed to
be a super sleek spy but so many of
these clunky and dull looking scenes did
nothing to further that concede this
came to a head after died another day
when the Bond movie producers decided to
reboot the franchise and make the next
film more grounded and realistic
although a great new actor a return to
practical effects and a stripped-down
script all helps of the new dedication
to realism the cinematography was
arguably the biggest component that
needed an update cinematography is
responsible for creating the look of the
film dictating the lighting composition
and camera movement of every shot
studying the film it becomes clear that
there are two main principles that guide
the distinctive cinematography of Casino
Royale move the camera and reflect the
mood so what exactly does that mean
to begin let's talk about how Casino
Royale moves its camera differently from
all other Bond films for example say the
script calls for a scene where Bond is
talking to M as M paces around the room
you could film the scene with fairly
standard coverage painting the camera to
keep both her and bond in frame or you
could have the camera track m's movement
emphasizing her Restless mindset and
using a tighter frame to help foster a
connection to her character here's
another example two scenes that show an
establishing shot of a car arriving at a
new location
notice how the camera staying still
isn't as engaging viewers eyes are
naturally more attracted to increased
movement it's the reason why still
images on television or YouTube videos
often have an added camera zoom or pan
compare this first scene of bond running
with this second scene notice how this
is much more exciting and more
effectively conveys urgency and speed
here are a couple other things that
intelligent camera movement can do
exhibit the chaotic nature of a new
location amplify a character's dynamic
motion convey multiple pieces of
information at once and the list goes on
however adding movement to a shot
doesn't always make it better
non-stop camera movement can be
distracting and there generally needs to
be some sort of motivation for the
camera to move for example this
interrogation scene from Die Another Day
take a look at this strange camera
movement at the end of the first shop
there's no reason for the camera to move
to the right for all of its great camera
movement Casino Royale still knows when
not to move the camera like early in the
film when the sheaf is playing poker on
his yacht the camera is completely
stationary emphasizing the sheafs full
control of the poker game discussing how
camera work influences the tone of a
scene takes us to casino rails second
principle of cinematography reflecting
the mood every film has a mood or tone
in the Godfather the story's focus on
its characters internal battle between
good and evil is mirrored in its use of
dark and shadowy lighting lawrence of
arabia's epic story is emphasized with
expansive landscapes and uses seventy
millimeter film to create a massive
frame
the mood of every Bond film is suave in
each film bond goes around solving
mysteries picking up women and narrowly
escaping enemy attacks
he wears nice suits and has a very
particular drink order shaken not
stirred
but this sleek demeanor is rarely
reflected in the drab cinematography
what the cinematography in Casino Royale
does so well is that it's just as
stylish as its protagonists for the
duration of the film emphasizing bonds
sleek nature and the covert world that
he inhabits here's an example let's say
there's a simple line in the script that
describes bond grabbing a gun from the
glove compartment of his car you could
do it in two shots using an insert or if
you want to emphasize the sleek nature
of the car you can do it all in one shot
again let's say there's another basic
scene that needs to be filmed this time
it's Bond talking to a woman in bed
arguably where James Bond is that is
Bond deist you could shoot the scene
with flat lighting and standard
composition or you could shoot the scene
with stylized lighting interesting
camera angles and then end the scene
with a fantastic shot like this and
there are many different ways that
Casino Royale uses stylish
cinematography to enhance the film it
uses lighting to emphasize emotions
tilted camera angles to create a sense
of imbalance and color schemes to
reflect character traits every scene in
Casino Royale feels like a scene that is
distinct to a spy movie Casino Royale is
so confident in the effectiveness of its
sleek cinematography to capture the
essence of Bond that instead of putting
the iconic animated women in the title
sequence like every other Bond film it
creates a better version of the shot in
camera and it's shots like this that
combined camera movement with a suave
cinematic style that create some of the
best sequences in the film for example a
scene where a moving camera conveys the
sense of speed and urgency and the
stylish shot composition adds to the
thrill how about a shot that expertly
communicates the location and distance
between characters
need to have bond transition from one
conversation to another you could do it
using several clunky cuts or you could
do it with one smooth camera movement
after the success of Casino Royale 2012
Skyfall actually doubled down on
cinematography hiring legendary
cinematographer Roger Deakins to create
stunning set pieces and compositions
putting cinematography at the forefront
of the film was applauded by critics and
audiences alike and helped Skyfall
become the highest-grossing Bond film
ever Casino Royale demonstrates that
with a little bit of extra effort care
and strong cinematic principles you can
completely reinvent the cinematic look
of a franchise and proves that it's
worth the trouble when you can transform
this into this